da tutti ragazzi e benvenuti avessero
video sono fa dj sì ne ho tanti di
questi cappelli comunque ragazzi prima è
uscito un dlc di hammond e slip come
recentemente chiara quel joe coro che
avevo fatto quando c'erano gli uomini
primitivi praticamente ragazzi è una
cosa tipo ecco proprio logo perfetto
voglio vedere pubblicato su curioso di
vedere che cos'è perché tipo è uscito
gli ex a sonora cerna ovviamene vita
come la madonna però io sono in pigiama
giusto perché mi sta toccando il birillo
senti bambini ecco non perché sto
bambino che poi una bambina non è un
bambino prove ancora peggio come cazzo
ci sono finiti di me lo spiego non lo so
perché c'è almeno il gioco principale
avere un senso mi sono perso mi faccia
giocare con voi visto che sono sono un
bel bambino ad essere un bambino è
bellissimo ricordo
posso posso gattonare ragazzi giorno la
mamma ha detto che non si gioca con
queste cose brutte
perché ci si fa male ecco visto ho detto
io che succede sono morti tutti
ma sono sono in una nella mia culla
ma mai lasciato per caso la finestra
aperta non perché porca [ __ ] hanno
infatti è veramente aperta
come non capire dove dove cazzo abito in
antartide finita si può uscire grazie mi
hanno detto che sono troppo bravo a fare
l'equilibrista poi m'han detto di non
farlo me lo faccio lo stesso perché sono
trans che io mi fa una pippa ma di
quelle potenti proprio due vado certo
sta scalando il giusto giustamente la
maniglia e amica censiti non si può
avere un ghiacciolo già buongiorno ma
che cazzo si ascolta mills sei molto
coccoloso posso farti una carezza tipo
così va entrando pure lo yeti da qua
dentro
mi spiegate perchè alla fine sap e posso
uscire è che da visto che fuori fa così
caldo e può estate della madonna
coprenti gli occhi perché sarà una cosa
violenta ok
vabbè ci abbiamo provato andiamo a farci
una pizza e ci potrei passare dico come
cazzo faccia liberare sto tizio un
carillon tocca lyon ciocia un'aura
potentissima hai visto che bravo detto
libera minori da adesso questo che mio
grazie è molto gentile
ascoltami ma chi cazzo sei dynamo dove
lo è perché c'è una motosega perché è un
bambino dovrebbe giocare perché possiamo
uscire a sta cazzo di stanza che bravo
bambino che spegne le luci anche per
risparmiare energia permesso non è la
sua casa mi voglio proprio andare in
giro scandali ma dov'è finito il gufo
che c'era prima va byrne importano
estintore che dieci volte più grosso di
me giustamente buongiorno a tutti che
bella casa sentite sono un bambino che
si è perso si fatica a buongiorno
qualcuno ha dimenticato di falsi la
ceretta o sbaglio alcune mi spiegate
perchè sono in una casa ho trovato una
sveglia
adesso sono invincibile cioè questi
buongiorno cosa state facendo sport
calzoni capitan c'è un albero che gira
per casa ci sono di tizi bianchi che si
ingrossano nella stanza nella stanza da
letto neanche un cammino un cazzo di
teramo si fa qualcosa
niente mamma mamma mamma voglio
l'omogeneizzato e subito nuti è che
scappi facciamo così prendo roba io dal
frigo perché il suo seme non sei capace
a fare la mamma mangio io questo cos'è
il cibo per cani andrà benissimo perché
mia mamma è sparita ovviamente le chiudo
così le finestre giusto cenato passi
intrappolato ascolta zio aria li ho
subito a famiglia dove trovare un altro
camion con un ora potentissima minchia
che mia della madonna
porca [ __ ] no alla famiglia come
faccio a rivelare quel tizio che non c'è
non ce li ho più i cali ogni credo è ma
come cazzo ti chiudo la finestra si è si
scioglie la neve subito tipo che poi
ragazzi tipo si scioglie tutto tranne
tra nel ghiaccio del pupazzo fantastico
con lo score tex giustamente quello stop
il coltello el'ha ma avete mai visto un
bambino di due anni girare come un
coltello grosso così ce l'ho fatta
suscita solo se questo uno stereo
ragazzi ho trovato lo stereo con laura
potentissima si è sciolto tizio si però
non ti butta qualcuno mi spiega come fa
entrare negli oggetti e inutile che
festeggi perché c'è tutto da lavare
quindi dati una cassa di mossa hai
capito che devi cucinare non lo so
perché magari non capisci quindi io
faccio capire fammi un [ __ ] panino
che ciò fa sparire la gente sparisce a
caso allora di qua c'è la tipo l'albero
prima quindi non ci andrei tanto
mamma mi fai per favore la colazione è
poco non c'è verso [ __ ] quindi
dovrei esser vicino in qualche modo alla
vita eco farlo trovato delle mele
fortunatamente una banana adesso sono
invincibile si castra giorno bellissimo
uomo c'è una mela guida melas è andato
bene e la potenza della banana ragazzo
lo quella sentite io vado dove c'era
prima lui così non lo trovo più però io
ho una banale una banana o una banana
non rompere cazzo 9 cacciavo brave il
più perfetto la voce di sottofondo non è
che mi consola vita che li ho una banana
o una banana ragazzi e ragazze ragazzi
cantata dai montatori qatar e iva
infatti arriva e fa male una banana in
faccia ti giuro che fa male hai voluto
un bastardo dov'è dove l'ho perso
qualche merda 2 cazzo vecchi giocate la
lancio e la latta lo giuro da affanculo
perle non sapevo che arriva sei morto è
vero che si muove morto è morto da perte
è stato sconfitto dalla potenza e la
supremazia della banana amico mio non
puoi far niente braga qualcuno c'ha
voglia di spiegare dove dovrei trovare
la roba in sostanza per i maschi e torni
il tizio possibile non ho mai visto la
vista non ha visto che non mi può vedere
sono sopra una sedia figurati se mi vede
sopra una sedia la pistola verso offre
una sedia in mezzo alla stanza non si
vede devo trovare l'ho preso l'ho preso
preso veloce minchia che lancio della
madonna
ok se chiuso una cassetta ho preso la
capasso metterla giusta se c'è io metto
le casse ma chissà che bella cassetta
che sarà ragazzi fantastico
e vabbè però mi avete rotto i [ __ ]
nora galan è possibile se diventa al
ghiaccio ha fatto talmente schifo vedere
i teletubbies che si è liberata la
bambina va bene così che mammina volta
minuti mi guardi musiche ecco l'ho presa
ascolta no no no no non ci siamo capiti
manco per impegno e non ci siamo capiti
veloce veloce la cielo c'è più dvd
ecco non mi apre è non mi hai trono mai
trovato mi dispiace se ne son chiuso
quindi adesso melo pupi tutto bravo zio
bravo se n'è andato ma veramente non è
ovviamente ma non mi ha veramente visto
che mi sono infilato va dentro alla
ragazzetto sono tornati perché siamo non
me ne frega niente borsa che tra essi ci
si no la inutile che ti spegne pagati
riaccendo anche duemila volte noi stiamo
andare perché sto andando nello
scantinato perché no perché io devo
scendere
no non c'è ma ovvio chiamiamo anche
godzilla già che ci siamo che cazzo fai
mi aprì a brava primi st porta perché ci
sono tagli arrivano due schiaffi
qualcuno mi spiega perchè sono sceso qua
sotto che non volevo neanche scenderci
life che cos'è perché si è acceso il
camino poi cosa mi dice questo cammino
non è proprio il massimo
ok con come non detto via via via via
via via via di s cosa perché cavino sta
tentando di mangiarmi vivo merda è
insieme
la luce
ragazzi se per caso il camino di casa
tenta di mangiarvi vivi accendete la
luce perché non succede ma [ __ ]
no no no no no no ok volta stavolta ce
l'ho fatta ascoltami
e l'alternativa l'omino bianco questo
posso buttarlo fuori no ah sì posso mi
spiace però non mi stava simpatico ho
chiuso la fiamma guarda che bravo
bambino che chiude le finestre poi non
stuprarmi per favore che devo passare
novero è stato buono stavolta perfetto
ok ho trovato un altro pupazzo non ho
capito bene che cos'è ma non in poi
fatemi accendere sta roba è visto che
bravo che si liberano sei uscito da solo
prefetto posso prenderlo perchè mi manca
mi manchi alla collezione ne ho quattro
contiene devo prendere giusto per capire
non ho capito quanti ne dovrei prendere
ma va bene o quattro anni basta ti
ammazzo ti ammazzo arriva un ceffone di
quelli che non è veloce già fatta ci ho
fatto io ho fatto così ampi già pronto
nativo mi sembra un uomo impiccato sul
soffitto prova bel giorno sono farage e
scontate devo soltanto non si può aprire
perfetto mi manca credo un pupazzo
perché sono migliaia che non mi faccio
domande qualcuno mi spiega cosa devo
chiudere che ragazzi sono più di tutto
ma anche il tuo buco del ecco ecco ma
ripensandoci torna anche indietro e la
regale porte semichiuse nomi perché le
porte si perchè perchè abbiamo
apprezzato tanto lo so già che non c'e
nessuno processo noemi lei mi chiudo
anche dentro perché sono un cattivo
ragazzo
bene così perfetto grazie mille ma chi
cazzo sei senso ma perché ciò sostanze
strane in casa cos'è vediamo pupa ho
trovato l'altro pupazzo ancora come
faccio a raggiungerlo forse allora ci
posso fare chi è che ha aperto la porta
non mi piace questa situazione di merda
allora io non so chi aperto devo fare le
scalate assurde per trovare dei cazzoni
pupazzi come ci siete finiti mi spiegate
che ci sia per ascoltati o ti prendo lo
so che c'è il freddo
nella finestra ma son cazzi tuoi e non
erano mi viene a tartassare i maroni e
io glielo detto avete sentito tutti e mi
fate capire tu sei delle voci che
provengono l'acqua dentro perché ci sono
cose cosa sta succedendo perché io team
e io ho un coltello o un piatto non ha
un cazzo si smaterializzano è la e la
mia mamma che sta traslocando ma questo
probabilmente uno è una storia venete i
genitori visto bambino hanno liti di
bambino a scusate scusate mi hanno
litigato è praticamente lui vede c'è la
bambina vede delle vede quello che
succede questo succede al mi ami aver
sbarrato ovviamente la strada fantasy
grazie ma io vado avanti di qua e anche
se li metti la roba davanti non me ne
sbatte ma perché madonna quanti cazzo mi
piacerebbe in casa mio dio
eccola no è la giacca i miei ma posso
mai uscire io in pigiama e se anche un
po stronza ragazzi
ragazzi io esco prima che qualche albero
brutto mi stupri a un po freddo ma sono
dettagli sono uscito ragazzi però hanno
capito dove sto andando sono ps
ovviamente in mezzo alla neve in pigiama
perfetto ma finisce come tutto iniziato
tipo cos'è ipad e fazzo ho trovato tutto
la toga calma mi hai visto che papà ti
ha trovato adesso abbracciami bravo così
ti ho trovato che che caso concorso cosa
tocchi con sato molla la ma non ho mai
fatto neanche l'omogeneizzato non
cagarmi di striscio non toccarmi perché
si sporca di vino sulla maglietta che
non puoi farmi che basta no io io tamata
ammazzo di botte o madonna il mio prof
anno non può finire così perché i miei
libri amazon o [ __ ] vaffan no non me
lo permette no non mi fate di tornare
indietro subito me ne sbatto se c'era
mia ma non me ne frega niente io non
dormo più la gabbia passano le notti a
piangere sono convinto è stato
bellissimo tranne il fatto che non son
riuscito a salvare il mio pupazzo
preferito quindi [ __ ] quello che
li lc vi sia piaciuto a me è piaciuto un
casino a beckham on the sleep era già
bello di suo un ragazzi se il video è
piaciuto
mi piace anche a pagina di facebook e
come non evita trovata una descrizione
se non si lavora si rischia temi ci
dividiamo il prossimo video ecco questo
è cui stai calma perché non ho preso il
pupazzo di prima convinto proprio forse
dovresti discreti rich 20 euro prossimo
vito quella ragazzi